hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space 2 okay we're
making our way down to the solar array
okay um I need these gap ah
ah come on
no hey baby
really see for yourself
yeah he's going crazy he's gonna murder
everyone I shouldn't trust that guy
people don't seem to handle the marker
nearly as well ah ah electric app people
don't seem to handle the marker is he oh
my god no ah let's check out Jimmy's
as well as Isaac does as I was trying to
say because Isaac seems young he has his
episodes but he's keeping his cool
otherwise what we're like a gap
very good job killed yourself what
inventory all no way not with ammo okay
I need to use a little health pack oh
hello down on I didn't kill you emmet
what have I put you in stasis
that'll work right will you spit oh that
didn't kill you oh whatever I'll just
lie real quick ah I'm okay your life
not for long
great work there bucko I had some baby
yummy room down under guard 1 hey you
and give me a good yeah
oh no I don't have been Toria then
apparently me reload my guns here this
one area okay we're good now what all
those babies go oh hey
nabis ah boom what's your wow I look
[ __ ] oh I hit up I'm gonna hit you with
a loot her chair I didn't do anything
come on kill you kill you kill you kill
you there we go
Isis you're not a baby ah come on
execute
there we go well I popped another one of
those things having a wasting stop
there's a baby got yeah yeah Oh give me
the money show me the money
oh this is upstairs to that place
oh that was a long way around hi baby
I bought in yeah oh come on BAM oh no am
I already almost had a I am holy [ __ ]
I'm out of lunches Indiana Oh hot damn
I'm actually what oh no you don't
oh yeah ah ah goddamn it give me
something give me something go
that's with me damnit those things for
some reason those things take me my
health down more than anything else
anything else they just destroy my
health if I it would have killed me
before I touched that safe point I would
have missed yeah this yeah Oh need that
remember how crappy the konjac be more
text log hem personal log Howard
Phillips they hate me they all hate me I
can see them all they're everywhere now
just perched watching me even aunty she
just goes she's just waiting until
Howard Phil finally goes crazy and snaps
like he did when he let the birds out
violated all the codes broke all the
rules
I'll show I'll show them crazy I'll show
them what it takes to get out of here
they'll have to come up here and clean
up all this blood and then one rules
will they make I'll break those two I'm
gonna go lay down I'll feel right what
blood did he cut himself
all right I had enough inventory space
for all that but running low on ammo
I do need a store soon I got plenty of
detonator ammo so if I can intelligently
use that keyword intelligently as in not
blowing myself cut off paper easy
Oh Alex ominous
I don't know if I don't let the beam
touch me or something huh easily easily
hello crap the walls were like pulsating
Ricky nope
Oh another elevator it's all this then
I seem to be going up a lot
okay so I got to rearrange the solar
arrays for something
protective complete directive added what
am i doing
looks like the solar mirrors haven't
been maintained for years round suck for
the space station oh I could go flying
around in real space uh-oh awesome look
at it all
wow look at that
whoa Ellie it looks like two of the
mirrors are out of alignment how's he
doing he's sculpt type of ventilating
but I don't know how much longer he's
gonna loft whoa I knew she would destroy
me again miss Ross dies so do my chances
of destroying the marker keep him alive
and get to that panel
I just that looks like the Ishimura
that would explain why the infection is
here like seriously I wish I could zoom
in on it if I if I had the secret rifle
I would do it but that looks just like
the Ishimura docked there haha
there's people are stupid okay I need to
replenish a heretic uh-oh two stations
right they're coming
boom Oh goodies oh man but my
inventories full I'm gonna do with all
the goodies if they're all like money
I'd be fine but I don't have space for a
lot of stuff because I have health packs
that I can dump if need be
oh look at all these goodies I'll get
there one mostly money and ammo for wine
rack
okay I'm just digging with detonator I
here in space what can go wrong
Boosh okay I need to go arrange the
solar arrays
Oh God Orion
okay this one's fine okay some of them
are fine don't know why they would go so
long without fixing the others but
whatever yes please just dump money AK
that'll work
reload that gun anyway yeah they only
give me one spear at a time talk about
cheapskates
well is there are plenty of recharge
stations no enemies as of yet but
there's that bulbous growth which is
probably to be a problem
what else Oh what is that ah what the
hell was that
kidding me what is you know you shall
not ah no way it's got little missiles
zooming around everywhere did I get you
did I what the hell are you anyway huh
you're like a body but your weight Ruby
semi on no way Hannah wait I got this
there we go okay got that and I don't
know a more no room for anything oh man
I wish I would hit me with this door
before I got here look at all the
goodies okay did I do anything wait
Oh actived uh oh well that's convenient
okay goodsoon actually there's more
goodies on the way so okay for me oh
this is fun I would love a game where
you just look for out fly around space
all the time that's another thing that
I'm worried about dead space 3
what if there's no space Oh what the
hell gimme what Al
oh ah
alright I'll drop this for just a second
till I can reload that gun and then I
reload I can pick it up damn it it only
hits 12 ah force energy I don't even use
the force guns Oh
med packs are way too useful dumb okay
so I need to go up here oh that's pretty
I think the Sun would be that big though
here this far out but that's just me
really I can do this just with my hands
Hot Diggity there we go oh so right oh
there's the Sun le1 down that definitely
wouldn't be better
what's that bit coming out stuff can you
give me a hand with this you're saying
real or what's on there I promise I'll
protect you no just get over here and
give me a hand something covering the
collector pan
oh my god this hungry there's thousands
of them they're breaking apart early
good we got they're heading this way
they're breaking apart what does that
mean I've already been here okay where
am I going is there another one oh hello
that doesn't help me how over there okay
whoosh boom more goodies that I missed
yay hello new goodies music is very
ominous
is there anything else is there some
secret Easter egg that I can find as I'm
gonna where's that weigh-in I bet there
is
I bet there's some secret doodad or
Easter egg something but let me just
complete the objective huh do that one
yeah that one
what powers my suit I've always wondered
that because suits like this they're
awesome and everything but something has
to power them
like some mini fusion reaction reaction
or an arc reactor
well well well now that's impressive
crossover - when the beam in heading
toward the transport hub they're
wrecking everything in their path
oh [ __ ] focus off me as soon as I can
okay how am I gonna do that way up here
they're gonna abandon me okay now let me
look around cuz I'll be one hell of a
way to dies to walk maybe my supposed to
just go back whyever there's another
Easter Egg let me know and then I'll say
that there there's nothing I can do
about it but whatever I'll just go on my
merry way
wha overshot yeah okay that was awesome
I love space parts
I love zero gravity and that was well
done zero gravity go down oh I hook with
the close of the government's victims
will they cut us off you'll never make
it down here and find their hope be
there
oh this is an ejector seat
oh crap
I was amazed Oh check it was amazing Oh
boom yeah oh yeah it seems dangerous oh
go right through the middle right down
about here what the hell oh that's
convenient right through the middle
yeah not doesn't have a middle oh
there's my target I'm not going to
survive this this doesn't seem good to
survive
okay
all right Iron Man okay buddy hahahaha
holy crap that was something
anyway my inventories so jam-packed
anyway that's all the time I got for
this episode thank you guys so much for
watching and as always see you in the
next part
bye bye